- [Narrator] This is
NASA's Perseverance rover.
And this is China's Zhurong Rover,
named after the Chinese god of fire.
And these two vehicles
are on a mission to explore Mars.
- The US and China are clearly
in a political competition here on Earth,
so it should not be surprising
that it has now also become
part of the space aspect.
- [Announcer] Roger, three seconds.
- [Narrator] The US is the global leader
with more than 50 years of Mars research.
- [NASA] About 20 meters off the surface.
- [Narrator] And last February,
Perseverance was NASA's
fifth rover to land there.
China is the newcomer with a Mars program
that started in 2006.
But the country has big plans
for its first mission, called Tianwen-1.
(people cheering)
- The fact that Tianwen-1
is an orbiter lander
and rover all in one
is a very gutsy move for a first mission.
- [Narrator] This ambition makes
the Zhurong rover different
from NASA's Perseverance.
So here's what these two vehicles
are carrying and what they can tell us
about the new space race
between both superpowers.
Since this is China's first attempt
to touch down on Mars,
a major goal is to make sure its rover
actually lands in one piece.
And it's expected to
happen some time in May.
- Landing on Mars is very difficult.
- [Narrator] Jonathan
McDowell is an astrophysicist
at the Harvard-Smithsonian
Center for Astrophysics.
And he's been studying space programs
around the world for over 40 years.
- It's harder than landing
on Earth from space
because the atmosphere is thinner,
so parachutes don't work as well.
And it's harder than landing on the moon.
You can't just use the rocket engines.
- [Narrator] So the Chinese lander
that will release the Zhurong rover
has an intermediate solution,
using parachutes and rocket thrusters
to slow down for a softer landing.
- You wanna go somewhere that
you maximize your chances
of a successful mission
because there's already so many things
that can go wrong.
- [Narrator] So China has
chosen a relatively easy place
for touchdown, a basin in
the northern hemisphere,
known as Utopia Planitia.
It's where NASA landed
its second Mars lander,
the Viking 2, in 1976.
- It doesn't have a lot of big mountains
or big canyons or cliffs
that the rover might fall off
and so it's a good first
place to try and explore.
- [Narrator] Since this
is old terrain for NASA,
Perseverance landed in a different area,
called the Jezero Crater.
- [Jonathan] So Perseverance has landed
at the edge of an old river delta.
So you have this landscape,
which is a mixture of craters
and mountains that are
gentle, rolling hills.
- [Narrator] It's a tougher
landing area compared
with Utopia Planitia.
But Perseverance is equipped
with a more advanced landing
system called Skycrane.
- [NASA] About to conduct
the Skycrane maneuver.
- [Narrator] So it helped
the rover hover above ground
while a computer vision
system scanned for obstacles.
These two different types of terrains
mean both countries
have packed their rovers
with different scientific goals in mind.
And one of China's main focuses
is getting familiar with the new planet.
- It has a pretty standard
set of instruments
that will help Chinese
scientists understand
what it's like to operate at Mars.
- [Narrator] China is bringing better tech
to Utopia Planitia than
when NASA did decades ago.
- The technology on the Zhurong rover
is probably similar to
what was on the Spirit
and Opportunity rovers that
NASA flew a few years ago.
And it's still fairly modern tech.
- [Narrator] So this is
Zhurong's multi-spectral camera,
which can take pictures in
different colored filters
to study various rocks on Mars' surface.
There's also a penetrating radar
that emits radio waves
and when pointed at the surface,
the rover can pick up signals
and collect data about what's underneath,
particularly water ice.
Like Zhurong, Perseverance
is also surveying Mars
but it's larger in size.
So NASA has equipped it with more tools,
like a helicopter called Ingenuity
that could one day help explore the planet
on a bigger scale.
- [Jonathan] It's the first object
to make a controlled flight
in the atmosphere of another planet,
which is quite an engineering challenge.
(NASA cheering)
- [Narrator] One of the main goals
is to learn about life on the red planet
and scientists say the best way
to do this is bringing
back samples to Earth.
So Perseverance has a robotic arm
that can drill into the surface,
extract rocks or collect loose soil.
The samples are then put in clean tubes
to prevent contamination.
And then these are stored here,
inside the rover's tummy.
NASA plans to bring back the samples
to Earth by 2031 in a joint mission
with the European Space Agency.
- Even though, in some respects,
the US space technology is
still the most advanced,
the missions that China's executing
are actually very impressive now.
So they've been catching up very quickly.
- China's space program
has enjoyed support
from the absolute top leadership
since the very beginning,
dating back to Mao Zedong.
- [Narrator] Dean Cheng
is a research fellow
at the Washington-based think tank,
the Heritage Foundation.
And he's been watching
China's space program
for more than 20 years.
He says the country's political system
is an advantage when it comes
to planning ambitious
projects, like going to Mars.
- Xi Jinping and the
Chinese Communist Party
doesn't face regular elections.
So China is able to make
longer-term decisions
and as important, sustain those decisions.
- [Narrator] And those decisions
are financially sustained.
So while there's little public information
about China's space budget,
Cheng says it's likely not a small amount.
- China doesn't provide those numbers
but what we do know is, for example,
China has four space launch facilities.
That's more than any other country.
- [Narrator] China's state-funded program
makes it fundamentally different
to how NASA works.
(NASA cheering)
- So the US, for example,
has talked about going back to the moon
for at least 20 years.
But with each Congress
and with each president,
priorities change,
funding therefore changes.
- [Narrator] For instance,
NASA's annual budget
hasn't hit its peak from the 1960s,
fluctuating more or less over the years.
And in contrast to China,
NASA is an open civilian agency.
It has shared its technology
and fostered a commercial space industry.
(rocket roaring)
- [Announcer] And liftoff.
- [Narrator] Which has taken over many
of NASA's launch tasks and
helped with space exploration.
So if the Zhurong lands
and operates on Mars,
that means China will have done more
and faster in less time than the US.
This success wouldn't just be a point
of national pride
but would also get the country closer
to accomplishing other space goals,
including building a moon base
and its own International Space Station.
- China is presenting
itself as an alternative.
With regards to the moon and Mars,
most of that is for political signaling,
political demonstrations to show the world
who has a more capable technological base
and a better political system.
(dramatic music)